hello everybody those of you who've been
watching my progress on this wonderful
computer file venture will know we've
been developing two themes so far I've
been doing some historical stuff that I
know about in person and also going into
some aspects of coding information
theory compression things like that
I think many of you realize that
although Brady started this whole game
off with his many many channels things
like numberphile periodic videos and so
on he's such a busy guy there's no way
in the world that his response to the
requests for many of you why can't we
have a computer file there's no way he
could have done all that as well with
what he's got on so delighted I am that
Sean here a colleague of Brady's known
each other for many many years has been
able to come in and just basically do so
much work so quickly on computer file
with me and with lots of other people
because you know we do welcome comments
we do read them very carefully indeed we
probably can't respond to all of them
let alone actually take you up on all of
them for various reasons but it's lovely
to have them and as you'll see they do
guide quite a bit about the direction in
which we steer this kind of effort as
part of the way we operate it's also
obvious I'm sure that this stuff is not
heavily scripted we have a vague idea of
what we're going to talk about but not
down to the last word we're not in the
business of doing smooth Discovery
Channel National Geographic type stuff
lasting an hour and in many ways with
those kind of operations you can get
good things but it's all a bit smooth
and slick sometimes we like to go for
spontaneity and informality the result
of that though is that occasionally you
will find we either forget things or
make mistakes or generally foul up one
way or another sometimes usually
unintentionally
and the first thing I must say on that
front straightaway and Shawn's grinning
as well is no I meant no disrespect to
Richard Stallman whatsoever at the end
of the mainframes and UNIX video I was
talking about a huge amount of work that
had to go on to convert UNIX utilities
as well as create a kernel that wasn't
directly ripped off from Bell Labs
source code and as I was saying that I
was thinking of all the stuff that goes
around UNIX that had to be redone
re-engineered and in particular if I had
to say one big thank you to Richard
Stallman and the new operation it will
be for GCC because without a C compiler
that you can freely use and able to
cross compile to just about any
architecture in the world it would seem
then you're going to get nowhere with
porting Unix
so yeah the the omission of Richard
Stallman's name was not intentional I
was thinking of him actually as I spoke
I was tempted for a while and many of my
friends told me to try this on with you
but maybe not but of course the reason I
didn't mention glue was because the
title of the video was from mainframes
to UNIX and as we all know new stands
for good news not Unix but nevertheless
all joking aside it has been very much
of a kind of collaborative effort and
one of the great strengths I think of
UNIX unix-like systems of all varieties
now is you can pretty well pick the one
that suits you it has in a sense become
a commodity I mean I'm sitting here next
to a open suzi system my far right and I
chose that really because the rest of
the department here uses it and a few
years ago that choice just would not
have been open to me I would have been
much more constrained in what I could
choose so I think all of that does need
to be said from the point of view of
listening again yes Sean Brady I've
listened loud and clear that many of you
nevertheless would like the story from
shall we say the late eighties early
his own words to be picked up and told
by somebody who knows far more about it
than I do yeah UNIX freebsd linux MINIX
knew the whole story there is a lot to
say but I don't think I'm the person to
say it
I just don't know quite enough about it